Brian won't win [ __ ] from ESPN joining
us here on the show how you been Brian
I'm great rich I'm in Southern
California no well good next time when
you're around here you got to come out
here personally but entering the Bates
are pleased to have you on the phone so
what do you think Tyler meant by that I
don't know and I've talked to some
people in the last 12 hours and they
don't know either you know one of the
things that you know ty when he says I
don't know it's kind of a tick it means
he does know and the guy who you just
praised there for the follow-up question
is Jason Lloyd of the athletic and he is
as good as any B writer in the country
and great question great follow-up
sometimes the great the best faults the
easiest one well the cab beat writers
you know I used to be one so maybe I'm
biased but the Cavs be writers allow no
BS they will be on your tail you're not
going to get by the Cavs be writers they
just
they've seen too much you know what over
the last couple of years you know which
three years ago in January the team was
19 and 20 they traded half the roster
two years ago in January they fired
David Blatt last year it was in January
I think was really February but LeBron
snapped the one offs about the front
office not having enough playmakers
something about this team and maybe he's
in credited to LeBron and something that
happens with him at midseason they just
get sideways and now I you know being
responsible I would say well the last
just because it happened the last three
years Vans going to finals doesn't mean
it'll happen this year but I also think
it's instructive that you don't look at
something happens in January with this
team and all of a sudden throw the die
on the ground and say oh this team's no
good but you know it's definitely
worrisome forget about the results on
the court if there's genuine issues
within the team and again I haven't been
able to identify what Tiger was talking
but I'd love to be able to come on here
and say this is exactly what's happening
I've tried have been able to find out so
it's definitely something worth watching
well one let's go straight for the third
rail could it be LeBron based on what we
saw last night where he I mean he took
over the huddle at one point Brian I'm
happening for years I know that but this
one this one in particular though
I haven't seen it that demonstrative and
that law did you write the social media
out outcome of that so it went on to I
don't know who put it on Instagram but
then Kyrie Irving liked it I saw that on
Instagram yes he did I I don't know what
the Celtics travel plans for the Celtics
played yesterday in London so either he
was on a plane back across the Atlantic
Ocean I assumed flying over the round
part of the earth or he was watching
social media in the middle of the night
in London but the reason that was
interesting is because if people
remember you know there were times where
Kyrie got barked at by LeBron in
Huddle's and one of the things that we
saw over and over on loops on
SportsCenter and other shows when Kyrie
demanded a trade or eventually got
traded was LeBron barking at him in
Huddle's so yeah that was my little
thought I thought you know low-key thing
a Kyrie of saying yeah I think that I'm
not there anymore but the thing with
LeBron is and Kyrie is is the is the
outlier when you coach
LeBron when you have LeBron your team as
an owner when you have a broader team as
as a teammate there are going to be
certain things about it that are
unpleasant he is gonna do things and put
you in situations that make you unhappy
but at the end of the day so many of his
teammates and coaches and owners have
been rewarded with great contracts with
championships with elevating their
entire status elevating their game for
most people rich the surcharges and the
side effects of playing with LeBron are
worth it and Kyrie was one of the few if
maybe the most high-profile to raise his
hand saying Wayne ain't worth it to me
and so this is part of what happens
whether whether he's talking about
LeBron or not that that was true
two years ago it'll probably be true two
years from now Brian when horse joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show so what
do you think the strategy is do they do
they make a big splash in trade deadline
rumors about DeAndre Jordan or whatever
might happen with any other star player
that could be viewed by their team is
expendable Brian they got two they got
two problems with that number one
the other Jordan if they traded form
today which they've been talking to
Clippers I mean it could happen but if
they traded form today he would make
them better tomorrow I don't know if he
makes them better against the Warriors
because the Warriors can put out lineups
that neutralize DeAndre Jordan because
he pulls him away from the basket he
also has one year this is it on this
contract and he also can be hacked out
of the game I think the better trade to
make is for a really good perimeter
player so that you can play your best
center at center against the Warriors
that's LeBron that's what they did last
year in the playoffs they put LeBron
basically at free safety had him play
defensive center and they were so good
and then they got to the Warriors and
they ran into a team where LeBron had to
work on defense because he couldn't just
float around and they got deep the best
thing they could do in my opinion will
be to get another wing player and
prepare for a series of the Warriors
that way but here's the other problem
rich the Brooklyn take a lot of people
slam it and say well the Cavs are stupid
they they should have known the Nets
we're going to be better it's going to
be the eighth pick it's not that
valuable look at the standings the nets
are two games
if Nets win the next two games they're
gonna that takes going to be the 11th
pick if the Nets loose in that couple of
games it could be the only two games out
of it being the third pick and this
draft is super loaded they just don't
know where it's going to be you know and
if I'm the Cavs I'm sitting here saying
wait a minute we could be trading a top
three pick here in a draft it might have
a couple Hall of Famers in it for a
rental player like DeAndre Jordan I just
can't see him doing it I think if they
use it's good to have to be on a guy
who's gonna be there a long term and
it's hard to construct a trade like that
because you don't know what the tick's
gonna be but isn't part of the next
couple of months to make sure that
everything's ready for LeBron to not
only win this year but keep him put Ryan
we could this is a circular chicken and
egg situation LeBron will not commit to
the Cavs going forward therefore the
Cavs have to protect their future but at
the same time they have to keep the team
as good as possible to keep LeBron it's
a circular thing here what I would say
my opinion on the matter LeBron is an
irreplaceable resource once he leaves
you will never replace them but the
organization could exist for another 50
75 years and you not see him again it to
me I would probably trade the pic and
deal with the rebuild long-term
made this same decision with Kobe they
sold out to keep Kobe they gave him the
50 million dollar contract at the end it
set the entire organization back they're
still recovering it but every time I
walk in the Staples Center I see five
banners up there that Kobe helped them
win to me I would do that but it's easy
for me to say that Dan Gilbert has
already been burned by LeBron once he
has for a miserable terrible years he
doesn't want to happen again and he's
hedging his bet and I did it but boy
this is this is a tough situation and
this is the first thing that I said when
they made the Kyrie Irving trade they
put themselves in an impossible position
for February because LeBron doesn't care
who's in the draft he doesn't care who
the best 19 or 20 year old is he wants a
man he can win with tomorrow and they
put themselves in a position where it's
gonna come to a head by February 8th
Bryan win horst here in the Rich Eisen
show a few more minutes left while we're
sitting there in Staples why haven't the
Lakers come out and given any sort of
public statement in regards to Luke
Walton what why do you why do you think
well I know it they don't want to engage
levar directly in the same way that
sometimes we might do you think what do
you mean what do I thought I was on the
hot seat how do you read that
no no because even if he is on the hot
seat they can't make this change because
though then then you give the impression
he's running the franchise Brian that
that's the problem I mean well why to me
it's embarrassing that rick carlisle has
said more and Popovich and Steve Curtis
said more in support of Luke Walton than
the franchise publicly yeah let me tell
you whatever you want to say about levar
ball he has smoked out the fact that the
Lakers do not support Luke Walton and
that is now crystal clear and there are
now guys out there wondering openly to
me executive coaching agents I wonder
who the Lakers are going to hire is
there a next coach because that is that
has been revealed here that they do not
have unconditional support for Luke but
they have to run they have to even if
they don't they have to
because otherwise it's going to what
would be worse what would be worse than
giving the impression that the dad of
their second overall pick runs the
franchise what would be worse than that
nothing in my mind okay well you you
know that they've had this discussion
right and they still elected not to say
anything so what is that again what does
that tell you man that's nothing crazy
that's crazy Brian I gotta be honest
with you that's nutty nutty well you
know your point is well-taken I don't
disagree with you but this is it's
amazing what this reveals and this is
what revealed you revealed that they're
not willing to back up their coach and
this is the lay up because you know tell
me [ __ ] if you back him up today you're
not allowed to make a coaching change in
in May but boy does it say a lot to me
and I and I know their excuse I know
what their excuse is but to me being
around the NBA for 15 years all the time
when you have some sort of crisis and
quote it's always an opportunity almost
always and to me when I thought if I go
you know what this is actually a great
opportunity for the Lakers they can come
out there on a nine game losing streak
let's come out and back our head coach
let's do it let's let's touch spin this
and use it as a rallying point for the
team and by the way they have won three
games in a row it's a good a good time
to do it so then if we're if we're
completely off the rails Brian if we're
completely off the rails
then who is Kobe telling Rob polenka
should be the next head coach of the
Lakers Brian well this is crazy talk you
want to know what people are saying
behind the scenes sure you want to know
what they're saying please what Coach
has LeBron tweeted about most recently
[Music]
guys who got fired this year and LeBron
tweeted about him so Los Angeles native
David is Dale now again this may not be
true the Lakers may intend to keep them
but what
telling you is the way that the audio
vents have gone down like I got I got
executive in my ear I got agents in my
ear saying oh yeah there's probably a
higher Davidson sale and again it may
not be true you know they may intend to
keep Luke and David since they all may
not even want a job I mean I'm sure he
does but oh yeah so my days are cement
even want to job but by not speaking
about it by letting it fester this is
what is created and you don't think the
players you don't think that this gets
to the players of course does of course
take that for data Brian when Horst okay
take that for data there it is okay
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience